[MUSIC PLAYING]
MANASA CHALASANI: My
name is Manasa Chalasani,
I'm a product manager here with
the Google Cloud Networking
Team.
And I also have
with me here, Greg,
who manages UI teams for us.
Arunima, who leads
UX research for us.
And Jason, who is a customer
of ours from Pivvot.
First of all, some logistics.
Number one, no snoring.
And number two, as we go
through the presentation,
you can go to the next
app, click on the Dory Q&A,
and you can ask us questions as
we go through the presentation.
Dory is just an
internal Q&A app that we
have to be able to manage all
of the questions at scale,
and we can kind
of get back to you
even after the session
ends, in case we're not
able to get to your question.
So we'll go through
these questions
and we'll also take live
questions at the end.
So over the past
few years, we have
been talking to a
lot of our customers
around how they manage
their Cloud Network, what
are the key pain points, how
exactly do their workflows look
like, and where they spend
a significant amount of time
while they're
troubleshooting issues?
And based on this, we were
building a suite of products.
So we thought what we
could do today is actually
talk through the top
issues that emerged based
upon those conversations,
introduce a few of the products
that we built based
on that, and also walk
through exactly how you can
use those products to be
able to solve those top pain
points that we identified.
And you'll also hear
from Jason, here,
around how he thinks
about solving these use
cases at Pivvot as an
additional perspective.
So thanks to all of you who
have spent a significant amount
of time with us in one on
one settings and workshops,
providing feedback to us
as we build our products
and iterated on them.
So here is what we
heard from you--
overall, I would say
we could categorize
these issues that you brought
up into three broad categories.
The first one was network
connectivity issues.
So think of it as everything
from a broad question
around, I want to know all
that's there on my network
and what talks to
what, all the way
to very granular
questions on how can I
resolve connectivity issues
to a specific port on my VM?
The second category
of issues that emerged
was around network
troubleshooting.
So when an issue
comes in, you want
to be able to very
quickly understand if this
is a network issue, number one.
And number two, then be
able to very quickly isolate
the problem itself where it
lies as it is the network.
You also told us
that you wanted us
to be more proactive in
letting you know when
some of your metrics
like bandwidth or latency
are beyond the norm for what's
average for your network.
The third set of
issues that emerged
were around network security.
So certain examples
around this category
were things like, you wanted
to understand all the firewall
rules associated
with a VM instance,
going to very
quickly understanding
if there was a very specific
firewall rule that was causing
problems for you,
and also identifying
who might have
changed certain rules
or touched certain
rules in your network.
So, based upon
those top concerns
that I talked about
right now, I wanted
to talk to you about
four specific products.
I'll introduce the products
and my colleague, Greg,
will do a deep dive on them.
The first one is Network
Interface Details.
So Network Interface
Details gives you
a VMs view of the network.
You can, in a single page,
see the key attributes
for that VM instance and
the network interface.
You can also view all the
firewall rules associated
with that specific VM
instance and the effect
that those firewall rules
have on that VM instance.
So that should allow you
to very quickly diagnose
network connectivity issues.
And also verify if only the
intended ports and protocols
are accessible for that
specific VM instance.
The second product
is VPC Flow Logs.
So VPC Flow Logs provide
responsive flow level network
telemetry for your
GCP environment.
Think of it as analogous to
our net flow for those of you
who are used to that.
VPC Flow Logs provides
near real time telemetry
without having any
performance impact to you.
So, it also provides
a granularity
that you might be
comfortable with.
You should be able to collect
metrics for, say, a VPC
network or a subnet.
Or drill all the way down to
be able to collect metrics
around a specified VM instance
or a virtual interface.
And it includes metrics
like throughput and RTT.
The next product I want to talk
to you about is Firewall Logs.
So firewall logs
get you visibility
into every single
connection attempt
against a specific firewall
rule that you have logging
enabled for.
So you should be
able to see and audit
all the connections that were
allowed, and those that failed.
And you should be able
to take that information
and understand patterns,
perform some real time analysis,
as well as be able to
kind of ship it off
to Google Cloud Storage
for future forensics
and audit use cases.
And the last one, the fourth
one I want to talk to you about
was Load Balancer Telemetry.
So this monitoring provides
you visibility into all
of your internet
facing applications.
You get metrics and visibility
for both the front end
and the back end.
And it includes metrics
like number of requests,
latency, again, for the
front end and the back end,
and the connections that
are opened, that failed,
as well as throughput.
So, we talked about Network
Interface Details, VPC Flow
Logs, Firewall Logs, and
Load Balancer Telemetry.
And with that, I
will pass it over
to Greg for a deep dive
and demo of all of these.
Thank you.
GREG FRANCYK: All
right, thanks, Manasa.
So, as Manasa mentioned,
rather than going
through the features
themselves, I
thought we would go
through a couple of demos
that showcase how we can use
the tools that Manasa talking
about in order to deal
with real life problems.
Right.
Sorry.
Could we go back to the slides?
Yes, thank you.
OK.
So I wanted to begin-- go
through some practical use
cases and things that
you encounter on a day
to day basis.
One of the things
that we realized
when we were doing our
research and we were looking
at the problems
you encounter, is
that you encounter a very
difficult or tricky problem
once in a while.
The rest of it is
death by 1,000 cuts.
So the typical use cases that
we find people struggling with
are very basic things,
like connectivity.
So let's go through
use case number one.
Imagine you're a
backend engineer who's
decided to use a new
database for your project.
You're developing it locally
and everything works just fine.
Now you're ready stand
up a test environment,
you create an instance
to run your app,
you create an instance to
run the database server,
you start the app, and it hangs.
Right?
Of course, it's, like,
Friday afternoon, you've
been working all day
to do it, it's 4:30,
you're ready to go
home, meet somebody--
hang out.
Unfortunately, it's not working.
So let's go to the demo and
talk about how we can resolve
or troubleshoot what's going on.
OK, so, I am the
developer, I'm happy,
I've set up my
entire environment.
Here's the IP address,
I'm ready to go.
I hit Enter, and it's hanging.
OK, It might still
be-- oh, oh, no.
An error has occurred.
OK, what do we do now?
So if you are a
network admin, you
are sure it's an
application issue.
And if you're a
developer, you're
sure it's a network issue.
Right?
That is one thing that's a fact.
So the developer will
probably, at this point,
start looking at
application logs,
trying to figure
out what's going on.
And the root cause
of the time delays,
here, are mostly
because we don't
know where the problem is.
Right?
So we don't know if it's
a network problem, yet.
But if we can rule
out the network,
that gives us a really
good hint of where
we can go looking next.
So let's see how we can use
the Network Interface Details
page in order to rule
out any possible issues
with the network or
to prove that there
are issues with the network.
So this is my GCP project.
Here's a web server.
Here's the MySQL server.
Ignore the suspicious
host for now,
there's nothing going on there.
We'll look at that one later.
OK, so the web server is here.
This is what I'm connecting to.
And the database server is here.
So let's click on these
three dots on the side.
And right here,
there's something that
says, view network details.
First, I'll give
you a quick overview
of what the page
contains, and then I'll
show you how you use it.
The top part are the attributes
that Manasa was talking about.
These are things that
we found were sprinkled
through the console everywhere.
They were on the Details
page, some of these things
were buried in subtabs on
the Instance Details page.
It was very hard to pull
all of this together.
So just by pulling
it all together,
we found that we're
adding a lot of value
by showing you the
things that are
the most important
to this instances
behavior on the
network that it's on.
And beyond that, we looked
at firewall rules and Routes.
So if you have a VPC
network in production,
you probably have hundreds
of firewall rules, maybe even
thousands.
If you wanted to understand
which firewall rules were
applied to this
instance, in the past,
you would go to the
firewalls list page
and go through
all 1,000 of them.
I'm not kidding, all
1,000, one by one,
decide which ones apply,
which ones don't, create
a list of those.
So, we thought we
could do that better.
So we did that for you.
So, these are the firewall
rules that are applying only
to the specific instance.
Taking things like tags
and other things-- service
accounts-- into account.
Right?
We did the same
thing for Routes.
So now we have a list
of firewall rules.
But that still means you have
to go through each one of them
and apply those firewall
rules in the order
that the control-- or the data
plan actually applies them.
So we took it a step further,
and we created the network
analysis section.
This is what's
here at the bottom.
So let me explain
what's going on here.
It's not necessarily
the easiest concept.
So we are creating a
two-dimensional grid.
On one dimension, we have
all possible ingress sources.
On the other dimension, we
have all possible protocols
and ports.
We run through all of the
firewall rules, one by one,
and then we open and close
port source combinations,
and then we come
up with a model--
a two-dimensional model-- of
what can access this instance.
We do it for Egress and we
do it for Routes, as well.
After we do that, we dump all
of that out into a tabular
form, most specific
IPs to least specific.
So I happen to know the IP
address of my database server--
it's 10.0.0.3.
Right?
I can check to see whether
the database server can
access this instance.
Actually, I'm not
interested in that,
I'm interested to see if this
can access the database server.
So I'll look at Egress
And see, hm, this instance
can access everything.
So it's certainly not an
outbound firewall rule.
It could be an inbound
firewall rule on the database.
So let's go to the same
page on the database server.
All right, that
was the web server,
here's the database server.
View network details,
scroll down to the analysis,
and find web server has
an IP address of 10.0.0.5.
So, scrolling down, here it is.
Everything is blocked,
except for these ports.
Now it's a MySQL database, so,
if you know what MySQL runs on,
it's 3306 It's not
there, it's missing.
That's the problem,
it's a firewall rule.
I can go up here and find, oh,
man, there is a firewall rule.
Someone did create it,
it's just disabled.
So I can click on
firewall rule, edit it.
Turn it back on.
Patiently wait.
Let's refresh, just in case.
Firewall rule is active.
I go to the analysis, and I
see, hm, 3306 is now allowed.
That looks good.
Let's go back to the error
page, refresh, and it works.
I know it's hard to read,
but it says it works.
It's pretty happy in
the corner, there.
SPEAKER 1: You're good.
GREG FRANCYK: All right, so
that was a use case number one.
Let's go to use case number two,
can we go back to the slides,
please?
All right, use case number
two is about network security.
So you're a network security
admin in your company.
Your company has a
process for auditing
all new sensitive systems,
like database servers,
to ensure that access is limited
to what's absolutely necessary,
and you're leading an audit
for a new database server.
So the one we just stood
up in use case one.
You want to verify, obviously,
that only necessary ports are
open for the documentation
of the dev team,
you want to understand what's
connecting to that server,
and you want to understand
what your security
posture is blocking.
All right, so if we could
go back to the demo.
I won't go through the network
interface details page again,
but I think you can see how
this would be very helpful
in understanding what can and
cannot access an instance.
Let's look at some things that
actually show what's happening.
All right, so we talked about
VPC Flow Logs and firewall
logs earlier.
So this is actual
information of what's
happening on the network.
Every single packet that's
moving around your network.
Well, not every single packet,
every single flow is captured.
Right?
And this is an example
of a particular flow.
So I've gone to the Stackdriver
logging section in logs.
I have VPC Flow Logs enabled.
I've hit subnetwork, that's
the resource that this is on.
And then, I look at vpc_flows.
Here is one object that
represents a flow that
occurred on the network.
You see some
helpful information.
So the 5-tuple is
nicely located, here.
And then some annotations,
like the destination instance
and the destination VPC.
So annotations that you can use.
So this is actual
traffic on the network.
We do the same
thing for firewalls.
So every firewall rule
that has this enabled
will generate logs.
So here is a firewall
rule that denied
a particular piece of traffic.
We have information
about the instance.
about the connection.
Again, the 5-tuple,
so, nice and familiar.
And then some information about
the firewall rule, itself.
Which firewall rule it
was, what the action
is, effectively, metadata
that's on the firewall rule.
All right?
This is interesting.
However, there will be
thousands of these records,
and we're obviously not
going to go one by one
and look at what's going on.
So you can take
this a step further
and export this into
BigQuery, or really anything
that does analysis.
I've chosen BigQuery
for obvious reasons--
it was easy, it was
a one-click option--
operation.
When I did that, I
constructed a query that
will take all
source IP addresses,
the action of the firewall
rule, the reference, as in name
of the firewall rule,
and the amount of times
that firewall rule was hit.
So effectively, creating
a firewall hit counter.
This coming from
the firewall logs.
And I'm looking at things
that are specifically
trying to access the
MySQL server we've
been looking at earlier.
A quick group by, and
then I order by counts.
I hit Run, and we give
it a couple seconds,
and let's look at the results.
Actually, I could
just hide the editor.
I instantly notice
that this IP address--
10.0.0.4-- is
being denied a lot.
All right?
So today, over 14 million times.
So this instance,
this source IP address
is trying to access
that database
server that we were looking at
earlier, and that's a problem.
So I go back, and
I take a look at,
what could that possibly be?
And if you were paying attention
earlier, you've guessed it,
that is suspicious host.
Now, why suspicious
host showing up here?
Because I'm running end map
from the suspicious host
against MySQL server.
So we got that
very, very quickly.
We see what's being blocked.
And we actually see that
some things are successfully
passing through.
I could augment this
query and show things
like port information.
Effectively, anything that
was on the firewall logging
record from before.
All right.
And one more use case.
So could we please go
back to the slides?
Thank you.
Use case number three.
So we talked about
internal use cases a lot.
But let's say your application
goes to production.
So you've put it
behind an HTTPS load
balancer for a lot of reasons.
What tools can you use to
monitor and gain visibility
into that traffic?
So in this example,
let's pretend you're
a Global eCommerce Company.
You're deployed
in three regions--
the US, Europe, and Asia.
And the site is made up of
different smaller applications,
so it's pretty complicated.
And if you've been to any
of the load balancing talks
that we've had about HTTPS load
balancer, you know it's global.
So we give you one IP address.
Customers connect to
that one IP address.
And it's routed to the resources
that are closest to them.
So, obviously, if
you're in the US,
you want to be served
by US resources,
and the same thing
with Asia and Europe.
So how can we make
sure that's happening?
Well, let's go back to the demo.
All right, so here's a
list of load balancers
that I have in this project.
The one that we're
talking about,
shopping-site-lb,
I'll click on it.
Configuration is
pretty complicated.
There's browse backends, there's
carts, there's a checkout,
something called
feeds, test-https.
And I'll go to Monitoring.
And in Monitoring,
we see right away,
the number of requests per
second across the backends that
are in this load balancer.
If I look at a specific
backend, let's say browse,
I get this cool Sankey
diagram at the bottom.
And the Sankey diagram
is showing something
very interesting-- the locations
here on the left hand side,
are the entry points of traffic
onto the Google Network.
Right?
So customers in North
America, their traffic
is entering in North America.
And typically, there are
resources that are configured.
For the purpose of this
demo, I've taken them down.
And as a result of
that, that traffic
is being automatically
distributed
by the Google load
balancing infrastructure,
mostly to Europe, and
a little bit to Asia.
The traffic
highlighted in yellow
is effectively out of region.
So it's being served
out of region,
and this is much
higher latency for you.
The customer has to go
all the way to Europe
and the request has come all
the way back in order for them
to be served.
On top of this, there's a bunch
of other load balancing metrics
that you can look at.
I won't go through all of them.
I realize it's
probably hard to read.
But we have things like
latency, latency to the backend,
latency to the frontend,
in addition to things
like requests and throughput.
All right, so those
are the three use cases
I want to go through.
Could we please go
back to the slides?
And I'd love to ask Arunima
to come and join me.
Arunima is UX Researcher,
and she'll talk about some
of the research that
we've done on this topic.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP:
Thank you, Greg.
Hi, everyone.
As Greg mentioned, I am Arunima,
and I'm a UX Research Lead.
And me and my team have been
working with a lot of you,
trying to understand some of
your challenges and pain points
and then bringing it back to
our fabulous PM and eng team
to work interactively
together so that we
can fix some of those problems.
And we, through the
last couple of years,
have worked across EMEA and
US with our customers who
are in different verticals
like finance, retail, health,
gaming, et cetera.
And also, we've been talking
to network architects, cloud
architects.
If we have not talked to
you yet, please do stop by
and we would love to
talk to you so that we
can get your feedback as well.
So, as we were trying to
organize this discussion
and this talk, we're
thinking, well,
there might be many different
ways of solving the same
problem, and you might be,
like, at the end of Thursday--
or in the beginning of Thursday,
it was the end of the session
board--
by just listening to us
giving demos are presenting.
So we thought it might
be interesting for you
to hear, actually, feedback
from your own peers
as to how, not only they
are using some of our tools,
but, you know, other
tools that they are
using to solve those problems.
So we thought that it
might be interesting
for us to invite Jason
Cradit, who is the Senior
Director of technology at
Pivvot, to come and talk to us
and talk through some
of the use cases.
Welcome, Jason.
JASON CRADIT:
Thank you, Arunima.
I appreciate it.
So as I mentioned,
I'm Jason Cradit.
I'm Senior Director
of Technology
at a company called Pivvot.
You've likely never
heard of Pivvot.
And Senior Director
of Technology
might not tell you a lot about
what I do on a daily basis,
it's a little ambiguous.
So I am the IT Operations
and Security guy, we just
have cool titles, fancy.
So Pivvot is a oil and
gas engineering company,
predominantly.
We focus on helping
our customers transport
oil, and gas, and electricity
from one point to the other.
We start by developing
analytical solutions
to help plan where to build a
physical asset in the United
States.
And then how to transport
it, construct the asset,
and then manage
it, and operate it.
We are based-- I am
based in Kansas City,
so all of you San Franciscans--
we are not Madison Bumgarner,
fans by any stretch
of the imagination.
But my dev team is focused--
or lives in Denver, Colorado.
And then, because we're
so predominantly focused
in oil and gas, we've got a
large Houston group, as well.
That's Pivvot.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: That's great.
Thank you so much, Jason.
Before we go into
some of the use cases,
can I ask you, why Google?
Why now?
JASON CRADIT: Oh, good question.
We started our journey
into the Cloud around 2012,
and we really wanted to create
an application for people
to use in our industry.
In our industry, oil and gas,
and energy and utilities--
it's not heavy IT, by any means.
My users are not heavy IT users.
So we started with Google Maps.
We wanted to make it
somewhat easy, and familiar,
and just sort of normal.
They're used to it on
their phones, already.
So we wanted to help them create
a fast and simple, intuitive
interface.
And then, we started
getting into that ecosystem.
We said, well, Google
Apps for Business
makes a lot of sense
for us to store
documents and collaborate.
And then, as we go
through time, we
started to just be
immersed in Google,
and decided, why not
be in GCP, as well?
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: That's great.
So it looks like you are
using the whole ecosystem.
JASON CRADIT: A lot of it.
[LAUGHS]
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: That's amazing.
So, next, Jason, we
would like to talk
through some of the use
cases that Greg demoed on,
and see what--
like, understand your
perspective on them.
Sounds great?
JASON CRADIT: Yeah.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: OK.
So let's pretend
that you are actually
working with a
developer on your team,
and who's developing
a new database,
and everything is
working great locally.
But as you are getting ready
to test in the environment,
and you create an
instance to run your app,
and then the instance on the
database and a new instance
as well, what you see is
that your app is hanging.
Has that ever happened to you?
JASON CRADIT: Yeah.
No, there's no
reason to pretend.
This is a normal day in my life.
And we have great developers--
so, if there's
developers here, I'm
sure you're great, as well--
but it always works on
their machine, right?
Always.
And yet, when they throw it over
to my team to go and implement
and production or put it
into the cloud environment,
we notice issues, obviously,
and it doesn't just work,
as we'd hope.
And as Greg outlined,
it's typically--
you know, they're ready to
get out the door on a Friday
afternoon, and then my
team has to take it over
to implement into production
or into a dev or staging
environment.
So this has happened
quite a bit, recently.
We've been transitioning--
I mentioned,
we started in the
Cloud in 2012--
we started traditionally with
a three-tier architecture.
And now, more recently, we've
been moving to microservices
as in architecture
and some serverless.
And so, there's a lot of
volatility in our environment
right now.
And so, through that
process, every little piece
we have to take apart,
and deconstruct,
and then start putting
into new environments.
And when we've used
Docker and containerized
quite a bit of our application--
and what happens is,
in a three-tier
architecture, you've
got, kind of, your border
network security defense.
And then, each tier, your
application, and so forth,
has its own firewall rules
and things like that.
In a microservices architecture,
it's not quite like that.
Right?
You start to have
millions-- probably not--
but thousands of firewall
rules that really define
your environment--
define the security
context of your environment.
And so, when you run into
this problem and it's hanging,
you just got to scroll through
pages, and pages, and pages
of firewall rules and data
to try to figure it out.
And, certainly, there's
tools out there,
and we've got great
documentation,
like everybody does,
about our environment
and how it should work.
However, you still need
to solve the problem.
You still need to find the right
rule to change to modify it.
And because I own
networking and security,
it's my team's
role to go do that.
So, historically, we would
scroll through the rules,
we'd search for
IPs, and things like
that to try to find
protocols, and it's difficult.
It was really, really
difficult. Very time consuming.
So with the new tools, like Greg
mentioned, the network details
now, it's like two clicks away.
Right?
So now we don't have to spend
all this time searching for it.
It's really quick to see the
instances view of its network.
Just like that.
It's amazing.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: That's great.
I'm very glad to hear
that the network details
page is actually solving
some of your problems.
And so, now you and your
dev can both have beer--
JASON CRADIT: Yeah, exactly.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: --at
the end of the day?
OK, so now that you and your dev
are having a very happy time,
let's move on to
the next use case.
So the next use case here
is, let's pretend, now,
that you are working with
your network security admin.
And you are, as Greg
mentioned, doing
an audit for a very
sensitive system,
and you wanted to verify
that all the necessary port
that the dev team has
documented are open,
and then, understand what
connecting to the server,
and determine what security
posture is blocking.
I'm sure with your
passion in security,
you have definitely faced
some of this as well?
JASON CRADIT: No question.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP:
Can you talk to us--
JASON CRADIT: Yeah.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: --a
little bit about it?
JASON CRADIT: No question.
We are very interested
in cyber security.
And in our industry,
especially, we're
helping transport critical
infrastructure assets
around the US.
And so, we care a
lot about protecting
our customers' privacy.
But it's also interesting
to think about,
our customers are
always comfortable
with us managing their
data in the cloud.
So we've got an
extra burden on us
to help show how
we're protecting it.
And in for years
in the cloud, it
was really easy to sort of say,
yeah, that we trust our cloud
provider to protect it, we've
blocked Port 22 to the world,
so we're good.
Right?
And then we had auditors come
in, and auditors are also,
sometimes-- if they're
here, I apologize-- but,
not always as
technically savvy as they
go through a network
infrastructure in the cloud,
versus when we used
to do it on prem.
And so, we run into
these two issues,
where we've got to
not only show Port
22 is blocked from
the world, but we've
got to prove it,
in some capacity.
And forever in the cloud,
you could define the firewall
rules, and they were set.
And you're like, see?
We're good.
Right?
22 is blocked.
But you want to prove it.
And you won't prove
it's been like that
for some amount of time.
Now, with firewall
logging, you can
start to go and look,
and see, and prove--
Nope, absolutely.
We've blocked 14 million
packets, you know, today,
or whatever.
And that's a
functionality that's
been lost in the cloud
for quite some time.
And now, it helps me rest
a little easier because we
have more of a defendable
posture when we talk
to our customers and auditors.
And it helps us just
convey the message
and be more
transparent, I think,
with how we're
protecting the data.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP:
No, that's great.
Thanks, Jason, for
expanding on that.
And you were also mentioning
during one of our studies
that when we were actually
coming and talking
to you about some of these
products, like network
details, VPC Flow Logs,
and others, you were like,
do I need to use them?
And then, like, slowly,
you started using them,
and now, you can't
live without them.
JASON CRADIT: Yeah,
it's really interesting.
It's funny you say that.
It's interesting to me that--
I grew up on prem, right?
And I used to
implement firewalls,
and built servers, and
network, and everything.
And there's tools you
don't realize you need.
And there's tools
that you can sort of
say-- you take for granted.
And you start out in
the cloud, there's
a lot of energy and
enthusiasm, and then
you're, like, yeah,
it just works.
Right?
But then you start to
really take it seriously,
and you're like,
man, that's easier.
I mean, It's so much better to
have instance level details.
If we do that on prem,
or could have back then,
it would have been amazing.
But that's sort of the
power of the cloud, right?
It allows you to
build new methods
for solving old problems.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: Awesome.
OK, last, but not the least.
I know that when we have
talked to you previously,
you have been like a big
advocate of monitoring
and having visibility
into some of the metrics
that Greg was showing.
So the last use case we had
is like, now your application
is in production, and you
have a HTTP load balancer.
What tools are you using,
currently, to monitor and gain
visibility into traffic?
JASON CRADIT: Yeah.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: If
you're using ad tools,
how are you using them?
JASON CRADIT: Yeah.
No, for sure.
I appreciate that.
It's interesting, as we moved
to microservices architecture,
we put a load balancer
in front of everything,
even if we don't need to.
And we'd just started doing
that, mainly because we
thought, we don't know about
our infrastructure, right?
And if we start putting
a load balancer,
we gain some of the Stackdriver
logging and things like that.
But then, also, we get context
for how our traffic is working.
And what's always
been interesting to me
is load balancing is very much
a IT, sort of operations network
problem.
But you gain situational
awareness of your environment,
like context for how your
traffic is actually shaping.
So it's been interesting
for us to put load balancers
in front of everything.
So we can sort of
visualize the traffic.
But then also understand
it, and understand
how our customers are using it.
And, as Greg showed,
you know, maybe we
forgot to set up logging--
it never happens,
guys, trust me-- but maybe
forgot to set up logging
and we didn't know our North
America servers were down,
or west coast or east
coast servers were down.
And now, by visualizing
it in Stackdriver,
we can see, oh, man, we're
routing to the wrong place.
We're creating a problem
for our customers.
It's adding latency
where it's not necessary.
So we like to dashboard
it inside of Stackdriver.
We do use another tool--
I think it's called Sumo Logic--
to do a lot of
our visualization.
More for dashboarding sake.
But my team predominantly
uses Stackdriver
when they want to really get in
to the nitty gritty of what's
happening in infrastructure.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP: That's great.
Thank you, Jason.
Anything else that
you would like
to add that, you know,
some of these use cases we
talked about maybe some other
stuff that we've not mentioned,
and you would like
to mention to them.
JASON CRADIT: Yeah, you
know, if I could shameless
plug some things.
[LAUGHS] We do take cyber
security really seriously
at Pivvot, and we're really
interested in helping
protect our customers data and
the data around their assets.
So we use a lot of
tools to protect.
All of the core
functionality of the cloud,
like firewall logging, and
BigQuery, and things like that
help us gain better context
into our environment.
But we also use tools of
the application layer,
like Trend Micro's
deep security,
I think I saw a
booth for them here.
It's a great tool and you
guys should definitely
check out their booth.
But I think more
than anything, I
think I made a comment earlier
that it's interesting to me
that you guys create tools
that we didn't know we needed.
And I really appreciate that.
And I know I've seen some
Googlers in the audience,
and I guess I would
say, thank you
for continuing to make
my job a little easier.
It's hard in IT
Operations and Network
to go get more resources.
We want to hire more
developers, and we
want to hire people who
can make our products--
get them to market quicker.
And that's good, we need that.
But what I really
need is to make
my job a little bit easier.
So I appreciate the
tools you guys develop,
and listening to us, and
developing them for us.
ARUNIMA KASHYAP:
Thank you, Jason.
So I'm sure that you might have
tons of questions for Jason,
and Manasa, and Greg.
But before we do that, before
we start taking some questions,
and have an interactive session,
I just wanted to wrap up.
As we mentioned
throughout the talk,
we've done a number
of customer studies,
on site visits, workshops,
design workshops, et cetera.
So if I see some familiar
faces in the audience,
but if we've not talked to
you, please do reach out to us.
We would love to talk to
you either remote, on site,
whatever, however, whatever
is convenient for you.
If you don't understand
and know your problems,
it's harder to solve those.
And we've released
some of these products
that Greg demoed today--
Network Interface
Details, VPC Flow Logs,
Firewall Logs, and also,
Load Balancer Telemetry.
So check them out
if you haven't yet.
And please remember,
there's a lot more coming.
So, you know, stay up to date
with our blogs on networking.
[UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYING]